[Musik]
es ist ein ros entsprungen aus dem
saarland fern
in hamburg ist erklungen kramp
karrenbauer heißt der neue stern
[Musik]
geboren wurde hayek an tagen wie
guttenberg zeigt mal wirklich dein
innerstes nach außen zeigen pure
emotionen wie sehen sich über kaka
freust freue mich wir müssen schauen ja
schon mal total ekstatisch jens spahn
ist politisch tot das ist vorbei könnte
er als letzten dienst an der partei
sondern organe zur verfügung stellen
und es gibt immer wieder theorien von
ihnen die ich nicht teile jens hat noch
eine großartige zukunft alles super 15
prozent weiß dass sie sind der neue
spd-vorsitzende das war doch reichen
oder
die jugend männer das war irgendwie das
war einst das war entweder eine eine
sammel schmiedete einheit irgendwo jetzt
kommt ihr frauen und stört ihn wie den
betrieb zum dessert
ich glaube das ist ein bild der cdu was
schon sehr lange nicht mehr stimme
und deswegen ist es gut wenn es jetzt
auch noch mal nacheinander war im
zweifel zwar jetzt mitgekriegt haben
dass ist auf eine gewisse art und weise
das ende des anderen fahrzeugs zu tun
die ba die connection von damals die ist
natürlich mit der wahl von katar ist sie
vorbei als die alte kumpel connection
ist vorbei ist man da auch irgendwo
opfer vom me to geworden wollen wofür
sind männer der cdu noch gut brauchen
manche dinge etwas anders die denken
bisschen mit dem kopf und mit dem bauch
der mann denkt halt eher mit sagen sie
das wort nicht aber eine politik macht
das selber ja und die männer sollen ja
nicht nur am rand der tanzfläche stehen
gefordert sich dann auch gerne mal auf
33 jahre von der tanzfläche runter
gezerrt direkt ins konrad adenauer haus
fühlt man sich da gebraucht missbraucht
naja es war ein besonderer abend
und das passiere union dass man
entscheidungen auf einer party fällt
hier ist das jetzt der neue stil in der
partei das dass man 33 jährige junge
unschuldige männer in der tanzfläche
ansprechend sagt du wirst mal neuer
generalsekretär
wir arbeiten mit allen mitteln sonst
geht das nicht war gestern tanzen
angesagt ich habe mir wohl komm hol das
lasso raus gewünscht aber da waren wir
auch schon bis in einem tv komm hol das
lasso ist kann ich gar nicht kippen
lassen
ich meine stimme gestern hätte ich gut
singt heute warum gerade mal ein als als
kleine eindruck dass wir gut
[Musik]
rosina was für eine wundervolle
vorweihnachtliche bescherung alle sind
glücklich und beseelt
wer fast alle etwas geknickt aber ja
versucht haltung zu bewahren
das macht ihn aus und was das schöne
zeiten der cdu
[Applaus]
ja da ist man sprachlos und mit diesem
schönen worten als fairer verlierer gebe
ich zurück ins studio
vielleicht war der fdp noch mal
versuchen
weiß nicht
bei nacht
[Musik]